bottom right of screen. Show text
on screen: SCP-682 VS SCP-1933]
SCP-682 Vs SCP-1933. Who would win? A huge,
hyper-intelligent lizard monster who can
not only adapt to almost any attacks
but also give them back - Or a fat,
drunk guy dressed as Santa
with Irish cream for blood?
Though to be fair, this Irish Cream will also
turn your blood into Irish Cream and kill you.
Foundation researchers siphoned off
200 gallons and fed it to SCP-682.
682 apparently really enjoyed this,
because it drank literally all of it,
even becoming intoxicated and collapsing
onto the ground, vocalizing loudly.
Researchers hoped this fluid was
wreaking havoc on 682’s internals,
but instead, it vomited up huge quantities of
this anomalous Irish cream, turning the walls of
its cell into Irish Cream, and subsequently
escaping to go on another deadly rampage.